hello readers today we're going to talk
about quantitative information in texts
but I want to start with a question
what's the best way to describe the way
a horse looks as it runs what's the most
efficient way I guess I could just use
words right the horse pushes off with
its back legs and then its front legs
come up and as the horse propels itself
forward both its back and front hooves
are off the ground at the same time as
it gallops it's like a series of jumps
listening to myself say that it doesn't
feel very clear to me at least it's
certainly less clear than this moving
image of a galloping horse
sometimes the most efficient way to
express information is to present it
visually to see it in order to best
understand it and so we're going to talk
today about graphs and charts your
friends and mine this video is no longer
about horses I apologize if I gave that
impression I did give a pretty obvious
title when I said quantitative
information in texts but to those of you
who I've misled I'm sorry now graphs are
one of many ways we can make visual
representations of data information you
can see news you can use and I guess a
question that follows from that is why
do it why make a graph and a chart what
does that have to do with writing
well visualizing data can make an
argument stronger let's say my
neighborhood is having a bake sale to
raise money for I don't know a carnival
and some of my neighbors have peanut
allergies so I want to write to the
neighborhood council to say let's make
sure that the baked goods don't have
peanuts in them so the whole
neighborhood can participate without
fear of having an allergic attack that's
supposed to be a peanut I realize it
kind of looks like a dog treat but let's
pretend that's a peanut now good readers
know that data is important to
informational texts so as a writer I
want to make sure that I'm backing up my
claims with a chart here's the text of
the letter I'd send to my neighborhood
council dear neighborhood council I'm
writing to ask that you officially ban
peanuts and tree nuts from the baked
goods on offer during our upcoming
carnival bake sale over a fifth of
residents survey
reported some kind of food allergy
please see attached graph if we want to
have their full participation in this
fundraiser we cannot permit foods that
will send them to the hospital all my
best David now let's take a look at that
graph these are made-up numbers in a
made-up situation but let's say I
interviewed 50 of my neighbors 40 of
them here report no allergies but 10 of
them do so we can have this bar graph
that breaks down those allergies by type
one person is allergic to strawberries
two people are allergic to peanuts four
people are allergic to tree nuts like
pecans or walnuts and three people have
multiple food allergies and then we have
this bar here that shows all the folks
that don't have food allergies that's
our that's the other 40 to put it
another way here's a pie chart of that
same dataset showing just how many
people in the neighborhood have
allergies in total it's just a different
way of looking at it this is all the
same data but we can see that the
percentage of people surveyed who have
allergies adds up to 20% of the total
something that's in the letter but not
the graphs is the idea that these are
very serious allergies if the wrong
person ate a peanut they could have a
medical emergency
if the council were to look at just a
graph alone they might say it's not that
many people peanuts are great let's
include them but combined with the text
the stakes become more clear and they
may better understand the consequences
of having nuts at the bake sale and
something that's in the graph that isn't
in the letter is the breakdown of
allergies by type maybe the council
could decide that the the one person
with a strawberry allergy is an
acceptable risk and that strawberry
baked goods are kind of obvious looking
and easy to avoid in a way that brownies
with walnuts in them aren't this visual
information allows the neighborhood
council to get my point more efficiently
than just the words alone it helps me
express a sort of complicated idea that
peanuts and other allergens in the bake
sale might constitute too much of a risk
to my neighbors and that they shouldn't
be allowed now there are other questions
like is this a representative data set
but that's a question that can be better
answered by our statistics course for
now think about it this way as a reader
your job is to look at everything that
is on the page not just the text
then think about what both the data and
the words do for your understanding data
and informational text are two great
tastes that go great together
one can support the other and vice versa
you know like like chocolate and peanut
butter
oh no sorry bad example like chocolate
and sunflower butter you know what I
mean
you can learn anything Dave it out